bonjour le rendez vous à montréal je
enfin ma femme et moi nous sommes
disponibles le 17 au soir le mercredi de
la semaine qui vient
et si vous êtes intéressé indiqué ça ici
et puis si vous avez des suggestions en
voie qui n'est pas chez ake où on mange
bien bas veuillez nous en faire part et
puis même si on n'est pas très très
nombreux ça sera très intéressant de
vous rencontrer mais rapidement criant
le certif
seule la croix que cette heure le soir
l'endroit ça reste à décider
et puis je vais vous avez a visé ici
donc si vous êtes intéressés dites le
ici le prix staline aurait vu entre ceng
à lady gaga et mariah ans de servitude
sa marque my hand soraya traits d'un
coup merci à bientôt